the french foreign minister said the
purpose of this g7 meeting was to
support ukraine in its war with russia
until there's victory
the leaders discussed fresh military
support with the european union
proposing a further payment of over 500
million dollars for new heavy weaponry
with the global food crisis growing the
eu is also working on plans to use rail
routes to export the grain which is
trapped in storage in ukraine the eu's
high representative joseph burrell told
me it was a matter of urgency the world
there are tens of ships blocked in the
ukrainian ports
by the russian navy
tons of wheat has been destroyed and
burned or stolen and brought to russia
the
looming
food crisis
is a crisis created by the wall
and we need to take thousands of tons of
wheat out of ukraine by rail
since the maritime
road is closed
due to the russian navy activities
attending this meeting alongside the g7
foreign ministers dimitro calaba the
foreign minister of ukraine
he'll be traveling soon to brussels
where the eu is proposing a ban on
russian oil imports he gave me his
reaction to the fact that hungary's
prime minister victor orban is
threatening to veto the plan even though
his country has been given an exemption
the
moment of truth will come
and we will see whether
hungary was blocking the oil embargo
because of its
national concerns and the attempt to
accommodate to make the european union
accommodate them or
they are doing it for some other reasons
of higher political consideration if
orban goes ahead and vetoes this package
what action should the eu take well i'm
afraid
the european union will face
a precedent a risk of creating a
precedent when the unity was broken
and
when the unity on russia was broken and
this will be the first
such case since 2014
i believe that it will cause a lot of
damage for the european union itself mr
caleb says he's also received a positive
response from the g7 to his demand for
seized russian assets to be used to pay
for the reconstruction of his country
after nearly three months of war james
bay's al jazeera weissen house in
northern germany